Sal: We now know all
about strong acids.
For example, hydrochloric acid
in an aqueous solution.
It's strong because it
disassociate completely into
hydrogen ions or hydronium
molecules, depending on how
you want to view it.
And chloride anions.
And it's an acid in the
Arrhenius definition, because
once again, this is an
aqueous solution.
In the Arrhenius definition
because it is increasing the
hydrogen concentration
in the water.
It's an acid in the
Bronsted-Lowry definition
because this thing is donating
these hydrogen protons.
And it's a Lewis acid because
you can kind of view it as
hydrochloric acid.
By giving away this, it's taking
these-- the chloride,
as you can kind of say,
it's taking the
electrons for itself.
So it's an electron acceptor.
So that's another reason
why it's a Lewis acid.
But in every case, it completely
disassociates.
So it's a strong acid.
Now, by implication, when I call
this a strong acid, that
must mean that there must be
things called weak acids.
And you could probably
guess what they do.
They don't disassociate
completely.
So let's say you have
hydrofluoric acid in an
aqueous solution.
It does disassociate somewhat,
so you are going to have some
hydrogen break-off of the
fluorine molecules.
So a hydrogen ion, and
that's of course
in an aqueous solution.
I was doing aqueous in blue.
And then that's going to
disassociate with the
fluoride, the fluorine cation.
But this is a weak
acid, so it's
not just in one direction.
It actually goes in both.
This is an equilibrium
reaction.
We know all about these now.
Which means that some of this
goes in that direction, some
of that goes in that direction,
and both of these
species exist in the molecule.
And just as aside, you might
wonder hey, aren't fluorine
and chlorine-- they're
both halogens.
Why is this a weak acid while
this is a strong one?
And this is just an aside.
This is something I always
used to wonder about.
So in general, hydrogen
likes to form bonds.
Remember, alkali metals
we included
everything below hydrogen.
Right?
We included all of these guys.
All of these guys, they have
this 1 extra electron and
they're on a valence shell, so
they just want to give it up.
And they tend to be very
willing to give
it up to these guys.
So if you have any of these
period 2 and below with a
halogen, you normally form
this ionic salt.
Where this guy gives away an
electron, and one of these
guys takes it, and you have
an ionic compound.
Hydrogen's a little different.
Hydrogen does have exactly
1 electron in
it's outermost shell.
It just has one shell.
But the first shell is
interesting because it's
complete when it only
has 2 electrons.
These guys wouldn't
have been happy.
If you gave 1 electron
to these guys-- they
need to get to eight.
So they're not happy.
But if you give 1 electron
to hydrogen,
hydrogen is pretty happy.
So when hydrogen forms bonds
with these guys here, it
doesn't just completely
give up the electron.
When hydrogen forms bonds with
our halogens over here, it
doesn't completely give
up the electron.
Because hydrogen says hey, if
you give me some of the
electron, then I get to 2.
And then if you share the
electron, you get to 8.
So it does definitely like the
bond with these guys, but
doesn't give it completely up.
Now.
Hydrochloric acid, hydrobromic
acid, and hydroiodic-- I think
I think I'm seeing it right--
these are all strong acids.
When hydrogen bonds with
any of these guys.
Which means it disassociates
completely in water.
But when hydrogen bonds with
flourine, it doesn't
disassociate completely
in water.
And the reason why is flourine
is even more electronegative.
So this bond between hydrogen
and fluorine-- so if you
compare hydrogen fluorine or
hydrofluoric acid to hydrogen
chloride, hydrogen fluoride to
hydrogen chloride, this bond
is much stronger.
Not much stronger.
I mean, you can measure in the
energy of the bond, and we'll
do that eventually.
But this is a stronger bond
than this right here.
And hydrobromic is
even weaker.
Let me draw it.
So this one is a little bit
weaker than that one and then
hydrobromic-- I'll draw it
as one line right there.
It's like that.
So these are easier to break, so
when you put this in water,
hydrogen sees these water
molecules that have these
extra electron pairs
floating around.
And and it hogged electrons
from here.
So there's a partial negative
charge, it's tempting for it
to disassociate with the
water molecules.
Well, in this case, yeah, it's
tempting, but it still like to
be hanging around.
Oxygen is very
electronegative, but so is fluorine.
So it likes to hang
around with both.
So it kind of doesn't completely
disassociate.
So that's why this one is a
hydrofluoric acid, is a weak
acid, while all of the other
halogenic acids are strong.
Well, with that said, the point
of this isn't to just
look at the periodic table.
Let's figure out what the pH is
when I dissolve-- let's say
I have 1.5 molar of
hydrofluoric acid.
And obviously, by definition,
since I've given this as
molarity, I have it
in some solutions.
In this case, I have it in
an aqueous solution.
Now.
You could look it up.
Well actually, I'll
just write it.
So every equilibrium reaction
has some equilibrium constant.
So the equilibrium constant for
this reaction-- I'll do it
in green-- and since this is an
acidic reaction, we'll say
it's the equilibrium constant,
or an acid constant, however
you want to say it, for
hydrogen fluorine.
Hydrofluoric acid.
Hydrofluoric acid is equal
to the products.
So it's the concentration of
your hydrogen ions times your
concentration of your fluorine
ions divided by your
concentration of your hydrogen
fluoride, or
hydrofluoric acid.
So HFl.
And if you look this up at 25
degrees Celsius at roughly
room temperature-- I believe
that is, but let's say it is--
you get a constant value here of
7 times 10 to the minus 4.
So if I have 1.5 molar of
hydrofluoric acid, can I
figure out what the pH is?
Remember, esssentially, I want
to solve for this right here.
If I solve for this, then
I know the hydrogen
concentration.
And then if I take the negative
log of that, then I
know its pH.
So let's see if we
can do that.
So.
I'm throwing 1.5 molar
onto this side of
the equation, right?
But some of it's going to go
and form that stuff, right?
So let's say x molar
gets disassociated.
So on this side-- let me
see if I can do this.
So I'm throwing 1.5 molar
on this side.
Let's say x molar goes
to that side, right?
And so let's say I have 1.5
molar on this side.
Once I'm in equilibrium,
x goes to
that side of the equation.
Or x reacts to form this
stuff, right here.
Disassociates.
So once I'm in equilibrium, I'll
have my concentration of
hydrogen fluoride will
be 1.5 molar minus x.
And what's my concentration
of hydrogen?
Well, if x molar, or x moles of
this, the way you can view,
disassociate, then we have x
moles or x molar of that.
And we'll also have
x molar of that.
Right?
If one of the disassociates,
then you get one of that and
one of that.
So these will be the equilibrium
concentrations.
And I think you can smell some
algebra coming our way.
So these are the equilibrium
concentrations.
Let's see if we can
solve for x.
So we know what the equilibrium
constant is.
It's 7 times 10 to
the minus fourth.
We know that the final
equilibrium concentration of
our hydrofluoric acid is the
original 1.5 molar we put in,
minus whatever disassociates
into the stuff up here.
And since x disassociated this
stuff here, I have x molar of
hydrogen, and I have
molar of fluoride.
This is just pure algebra now.
Let's see if we can
solve this.
So this is equal to--
I'm going to
need space to do this.
So we get 7 times 10
to the minus 4.
Let's multiply both sides
times 1.5 minus x.
Times 1.5 minus x.
Is equal to
x times x, is equal
to x squared.
And then if we multiply-- 7
times 10 to the minus fourth
times-- 7 times 1.5,
that's 10.5, right?
So we have 10.5 times 10
to the minus fourth.
That's that times that.
Minus 7 times 10 to
the minus fourth x
is equal to x squared.
This looks complicated, but
it's just a quadratic
equation, and there's
many videos on that.
So let's just throw all of
this stuff onto to the
right-hand side because
I like having a
positive coefficient here.
So if I subtract this from both
sides and add this to
both sides, I get 0 is equal
to x squared, plus this, so
plus 7 times 10 to the minus
fourth x, right?
I just add this to both sides,
so it shows up on this side of
the equation, which
is right here.
Minus this.
I'm subtracting this from both
sides of the equation.
So I get minus 10.5 times
10 to the minus 4.
Now, this is a quadratic
equation here.
And actually, I'll throw
you a little--
We can solve this quadratic
equation.
We'll get the answer.
In fact, I'm about
to solve it.
But there is an approximation
you can do.
Because if you look at this
quadratic equation, this term
here, x squared, dominates
this term right here.
Even when you have relatively
small values of x, it
dominates that term.
So if chemists look at
this and they say
hey, you know what?
If this term is so much smaller
than what's going on
here, in a lot of the cases,
you might be able
to just ignore it.
And then the problem becomes
very simple.
Because if you ignore this term,
it's still a quadratic,
but you don't have to use
a quadratic equation.
Actually I'll do it on
the side right here.
I'll just do it in a box.
Because this isn't the exact
answer, but it's going to get
it's pretty close to
the exact answer.
So in this-- I'll make a
nice little box here.
I'll make a box.
So if we just ignored this term,
then we'd have x squared
is equal to this.
Is equal to minus-- you would
add this to the other side, so
you would have plus 10.5 times
10 to the minus 4.
Or x would be equal do the
square root of this.
x would be equal to-- what?
See, 10.5-- I see you have to
put the exponent thing here.
So exponent for minus
all right.
And I want to take the square
root, so to the 0.5 power is
equal to 0.0324.
So this is 0.0324.
So if we make that simplifying
assumption, we've essentially
solved four our hydrogen
concentration, right?
That was x.
This is x.
So this is 0.0324.
And if we want to figure out
the pH, we just take the
negative log of this.
So let's do that.
So you take the log of it.
If you just press log,
that's base 10.
So you take the log.
And we want the negative of
that, so you just say minus
1.489, so about 1.49.
So it's a pH of 1.49.
But remember, I did that using
my little simplifying
assumption.
It does not solve the
quadratic equation.
Now let's solve it, just to kind
of confirm in our heads
that we get the right answer.
Because that's actually
the right way to
get the right answer.
So quadratic equation.
Minus b.
So x is going to be equal
to-- let me do it here.
x is equal to minus b.
So minus 7 times 10 to the
minus 4 plus or minus the
square root of b squared.
So b squared is 49 times 10
to the minus 8, right?
7 squared.
And then 10 to the
minus 4 squared.
Is minus 4 times 2 is minus 8.
Minus 4 times a, which
is 1, times c.
Well, c is a minus sign there--
we have this minus
sign, so it becomes plus.
So 4 times 10.5 times 10
to the negative 4.
That's what?
That's 42 times 10 to the
minus fourth power.
All of that over 2a.
a is just 1.
All of that over 2.
So let's see what we
can get in this
square root right here.
And notice, this is a very small
number compared to this.
This is really all we should
care about with the square
root, but let's just do it.
So 49 e 8 negative plus, so
that's that small number--
plus 42 times 10 to the
negative-- or to the 4
negative, is equal to that.
So that's this value
right here.
And now we want to take
the square root.
So to the 0.5 power
is equal to 0.06.
So so far, we get x is equal
to-- I will arbitrarily switch
colors-- minus 7 times
10 to the minus 4
plus or minus 0.0648.
All of that over 2.
And it should be clear.
If we subtract it right here,
we get a negative number.
This is already a negative, so
if we subrtact it, we get a
negative numbers.
So let's just worry about the
plus sign because we can't
have a negative concentration.
So if we add that to this right
there, so we have 0.06,
and then we have minus--
Actually let me make sure
that the minus is there.
So it's minus 7 times 10.
Right.
I just want to make sure I'm
not making a mistake by
putting a minus there.
No.
It looks right.
So let's see.
So we just do our math.
So we take this and
we subtract that.
So it's minus-- I want
to make sure you can
see what I'm doing.
So we have minus 7 e 4 negative
is equal to that and
then we have to divide by 2.
Divided by 2 is equal
to 0.032.
So 0.032.
And remember, this is our
hydrogen concentration.
It's also going to be our
concentration of, of course,
our fluorine ions.
We don't care about that.
We just want to figure
out the pH.
So this is 0.032, which
is very close to our
approximation before.
But now we have the
exact number.
So let's take the log
of it, and then take
the minus of that.
So the log of that.
And then you want to put a minus
in front of the log.
So the exact pH is
right there.
So our pH of hydrofluoric
acid is equal to 1.49.
So once again, pretty low pH.
But notice, this pH--
this is 1.5 molar of
hydrofluoric acid.
While 1 molar of hydrochloric
acid was even more acidic.
It had a pH of 0.
So even though we put more acid
here, we didn't get our
pH as low as when we used only
1 molar of hydrochloric acid.
Anyway, see you in
the next video.